[موسيقى]
شكرا شكرا
20% او اعلى منها ليه تحكيم السيوله
وتقليل الدوراره لان في مصر لو حضرتك همم
طبيعتي الفتره اللي فاتت حصل مضاربه على
الدولار في السوق السوداء وده طبعا ظهر
سوق سوداء ثاني في مصر بعد ما كان عندنا
سوق واحد هو الجهاز المصرفي ابتدى يظهر
سوق سوداء وابتدا يحصل تضارب على الدولار
مضاربه على الدولار
و30 جنيه وطبعا ده كان نتيجه المضاربه
لكنه همم سعر غيره واقعي وبالتالي خلال
ال- ال- الكام يوم ظهور لقينا فيه تغيرات
نتيجه للمضاربه دي ان ابتدا السعر ينزل
وصل 26 جنيه وبالتالي ابتدا يقرب من
الساعه الرسمي
في البنوكالب 25 وده بيدل فعلا على ان في
مضاربه في السوق السوداء وبالتالي ان
الفتره اللي جايه دي وفقا للقرض الشريحه
الاولى لمصر متوقع انها تاخذها همم هيتم
تحرير فعلا الصرف وهيتركه
[موسيقى]